un coup de frein brutal oresme de l'est
et c'est l'autorité chargée de planifier
le transport en commun dans la région
qui met le holà dans un avis qui n'est
pas rendu public la rtm estime que le
projet n'entraînera qu'un petit nombre
de nouveaux usagers et en période de
pointe selon les calculs de l'autorité
94 % de l'achalandage du rem de l'est
sera simplement enlever aux services
existants notamment la ligne verte du
métro et le train de mascouche sa veste
agité aussi offert une architecture qui
sans parti au 17 ministères du
gouvernement du québec qui ont aimé
d'importantes réserves des réserves
l'organisme trajectoire québec en a
aussi notamment sur l'absence de
connexion avec la nuit verte mais il
fait cette mise en garde on peut passer
aucun projet pour desservir l'est
avec cette sortie très remarquée de la
rtm le dossier est plus que jamais
politique l'europe de l'est s'est dit ce
média 6 milliards pour fragiliser les
services qui existent déjà 10 millions
pour défigurer les quartiers montréal
avec des pylônes affreux 10 milliards
pour un projet qui ne répond même pas
aux besoins des gens de l'est de
montréal les gens le veulent ce projet
et nous allons le réaliser on dit allez
faire vos devoirs et voir un peu plus
loin il faut voir les développements
faut voir les entreprises qui vont
s'établir sur le territoire la clé ses
voeux le premier ministre lui met la
pression sur valérie plan ni repos faire
un projet sur napoléon puis la mairesse
de montréal donc tant qu'amant la balle
et d'un code de madame plantes de nous
présenter un nouveau projet qui fait
c'en a faim
même son de cloche du côté du promoteur
du projet cdpq infra l'appui de la ville
de montréal et de la rtm est nécessaire
pour la réalisation du rêve de l'est
cdpq infra n'imposera pas le projet
valérie plantes répète que son
administration a listé les conditions
gagnantes pour ce projet notamment une
plus grande implication de la ville et
une intégration urbaine exemplaire ici
mathieu prost radio canada montréal
la mairesse de montréal est avec nous en
direct madame plein de bonsoir
bonsoir monsieur roy la balle est dans
votre camp dit le premier ministre lors
le voulez vous leur m de l'est dans le
projet que comme il a été présenté le
recensement
oui le projet on le veut et mais je vous
cacherais pas que j'ai été extrêmement
surprise est interpellés de la sorte par
le gouvernement du québec par le premier
ministre parce que quand vous étiez
moines à ceux qui ont le droit de vie ou
de mort sur ce projet là c'est
gouvernement du québec parce que c'est
lui qui paye qui sait la cdpq infra
parce que c'est lui qui fait la
technologie alors ce projet là on y
croit depuis joueront pas ce que vous
avez vu toutes nos prises de position
mais en plus on a décidé d'investir 500
millions de dollars dans ce projet là
mais clairement en ce moment là la
question qu'on doit se poser c'est
comment est-ce qu'on s'assure que ce
projet là soit le meilleur pour l'ess
parce que ils font du transport on veut
que ça soit efficace ont vu que ça
s'intègre bien dans le milieu dans la
ville de montréal puis nous c'est ce
qu'on demande parmi les conditions
gagnantes
entre autres choses on veut une place
autour de la table il faut absolument
que la ville de montréal soit parce
partie d'un comité conjoint ce que la
cdpq refuse et pour moi ça c'est un
problème monsieur roy parce que la cdpq
ce ça la cdpq son expertise ses les
trains nous la ville c'est l'intégration
urbaine alors n'est pas question que le
train arrive qu'après ce que des rues
des quartiers de l'architecte c'est ça
c'est non donc vous dites ou premier
minutes d'abord je le veux le projet et
je veux avoir une place autour de la
table avec les gens de la caisse de
dépôt et placement qui sont les maîtres
d'oeuvre du projet mais ce que vous le
voulez comment il est dessiné on voit la
carte je passe ou la voyez mais vous la
connaissez non j'avoue à trouver leur m2
laisse après honoré-beaugrand
entente parallèle avec le métro de
montréal ce qui généra des gens et à la
rtm entre autres que ça va fragiliser le
métro de montréal parce qu'il ya deux
options pour aller au centre-ville qu'on
pourrait arrêter le rem de l'ess a
honoré beaugrand quand on s'est prouvé
encore une fois monsieur roy ça m'embête
parce que en ce moment premièrement dans
les conditions gagnantes et avait habité
à 10 art présentement travail et doivent
remettre leur rapport prochainement et
je pense qu'ils se sont penchés sur
plein d'enjeux encore une fois moi je
veux pas me substituer à la cdpq ni au
gouvernement du québec meyer demeure pas
moins qu'on doit prendre en
considération tout ce qui va ressortir
de ce rapport là et pour être honnête
pour ce qui est de la rtm je pense que
le gouvernement du québec et la cdpq
doit également en tant que sa société
d'état fait de la planification
transport ahadi n'y cédera paulo il faut
il faut les entendre il faut pouvoir
travailler avec et monsieur roy je
réitère look et deux conditions c'est
d'être autour de la table son épaule ce
n'est pas un petit détail c'est vraiment
vraiment important parce que ce
projet-là doit en être de transport et
d'intégration et le deuxième élément qui
me chicote c'est que pour faire 7 et
grâce à l'intégration urbaine on parle
de plus d'un milliard de dollars et au
moment du gouvernement de le mettre que
ça fasse partie du projet et on n'a
toujours pas de nouvelles là dessus et
j'ai eu la chance d'être clément
entretenir avec monsieur legault tantôt
est le message que je vous porte
maintenant c'est exactement le même jeu
lui et d'également donc vous avez dit je
le veux je vous renvoie la balle il fait
moins de place à la caisse de dépôt pour
qu'on améliore ce projet là parce que
vous le dites on peut l'améliorer il a
gardé des tanks ont d'abord qu'on
connaît pas encore ce comité qui doit
redonner un rapport sur le la portion
rené lévesque en août à ce qu on peut
changer au bon moment mais êtes-vous pas
inquiète qu'on fasse deux jours pose la
question deux voies parallèles et qu'on
affaiblissent la stm le métro de
montréal c'est pour ça que quand la rtm
sous l'ère des drapeaux moi je pense
qu'il faut les entendre et je le ramène
ça fait partie des préoccupations qui
doivent être entendus par le
gouvernement et la cdpq qui pour
l'instant sont ceux qui y ont tous les
leviers la ville de montréal autour de
la table pour l'instant je n'ai pas
grand pouvoir j'ai mis 500 millions pour
pour justement montrer l'importance de
ce projet leur et vous avez raison que
ça pourrait avoir des impacts mais
encore faut-il pouvoir le regarder
répondre aux questions et moi je veux de
la transparence je veux de l'ouverture
qui jouaient autour de la table et je ne
veux pas que ce soit le mondial et qui
se retrouve avec la facture totale de
plus d'un milliard de dollars puis qu'on
fasse les amène à je mens après le après
le train mais entre vous et moi et comme
le gros bon sens que je dis là est ce
que la caisse est prête à vous faire une
place en terminant même lente autour de
la table je les ai rencontrés vendredi
dernier et c'était non du moins comité
conjoint pour eux sinon t on passe à un
train ça commence en premier pas
pressant on va faire les aménagements et
ce à son époux et sa population
l'intégration urbaine là le veulent ce
moyen de transport l'asie croît mais il
veut le garder leur qualité de vie ils
veulent que leur patrimoine
architectural notre vie de cartes et
demeure forte et ça c'est l'expertisé de
la ville c'est pour ça pourquoi c'est
autour de la table donc j'avais suis un
nom ce que monsieur legault va vous
aider je l'espère c'est le souhait que
je lui ai partagé c'est parce que moi je
veux que ça dans ce projet parce que là
c'est avec un rapport défavorable
monsieur legault pourrait dire à un an
des élections et moins mais savez-vous
se trouve impliqué tomber son panier
pour l'instant mais j'ai envie de vous
dire c'est une possibilité mais moi je
pense qu'il ne faut pas aller à cette
extrême du tout y'a tellement
possibilité est un projet de cette
ampleur là 6 milliards de dollars ont
levé cet investissement là qui ont vu
que ce soit un élève pour monsieur logo
pour moi et pour la cdpq également un
boulet marial est bien sûr mal un plan
de merci beaucoup on va reparler nous à
notre 2008 avec des gens vous connaissez
bien
expert en transport tout cas des
passionnés de transport merci beaucoup
au revoir merci et bonne soirée voir